ghost town britain empty streets
empty pubs shuttered factories
lockdown may now be over but britain is
still counting the cost
of shutting down the economy alongside
the death toll confirmation now of an
unprecedented collapse in economic
activity
when we were chatting a few months ago i
said that hard times were coming
and today's numbers show that hard times
are here
hundreds of thousands of people have
already lost their job
and many more will it's not a
sustainable situation to have
vast swathes of our economy essentially
shut down
and that's why we have been able to
successfully reopen bits and do it in a
safe way and as people
get back to going shopping or going out
for a meal or indeed getting back to
their office they will see that it's a
new normal it's a safe normal
and they shouldn't be too nervous about
the virus should they no i think as
people will see as they go out whether
it's to a shop whether it's to a
restaurant whether it indeed is back to
their office i think they will see
changes
and we want to try and protect as many
jobs as possible that comes from as much
of our economy returning to normal as
possible
it is officially a recession though that
word recession two successive quarters
of contraction
hardly does justice to it a 20.4
drop in the three months ending june
it's the worst quarterly drop
since this crucial statistic gross
domestic product was first conceived of
nearly a century ago in the space of six
months the uk lost nearly two decades of
national income
more than any major economy except for
spain the good news though
is that it did bounce back in june
growing 8.7 percent
a hopeful sign but it still leaves gdp
17.2 percent below
where it was before the virus struck but
for some businesses including this one
in london
now that bounce is starting to be felt
we've seen a massive
uplift in sales it's the first time ever
that our production has been out to the
beginning of december
normally we work in a six-week cycle so
that would take us to about
mid-september and september
and so for us to be this full is
excellent
promising news but the economy can only
bounce back
if it's allowed to stay open which
brings us back to downing street
there is another sense in which this is
unprecedented most recessions are thrust
upon governments whereas this one to
some extent at least was imposed
by this government as part of the
lockdown which raises another
question if there is a second surge in
cases would it be willing would the
chancellor be willing
to impose that kind of sacrifice all
over again
my personal view is that a v-shape
recovery is probably over optimistic i
think it'll take longer than that it
might be 2021
2022 before we're back where we are if
we have a second wave
the economy will be in real real trouble
the chancellor is now considering
scaling back the ambition of his budget
and spending review this autumn
another sign he's expecting more tough
times ahead
for the government and for the economy
ed conway sky news